first on cbs mornings a disturbing new
congressional report out later today
finds more cases of manufacturers
selling baby food with high levels of
toxic heavy metals the report describes
dangerous levels of toxins including
arsenic lead caddy cadmium and mercury
in popular baby food products the toxins
can be particularly dangerous you will
not be surprised to babies and toddlers
and our consumer investigative
correspondent anna warner has been
following this story she joins us now
anna this is disturbing stuff good
morning yeah tony good morning earlier
this year the subcommittee first shed
light on the issue of toxins in baby
food eight months later the oversight
committee has found even more brands
selling baby food products with high
levels of toxins legislators are calling
on the fda to more strictly regulate but
we found one company not waiting for the
government to step in
everything is in quarantine initially
when it comes here at his manufacturing
facility outside columbus ohio jay hyman
monitors everything for it to come here
it's already gone through an elaborate
qualification process he's founder and
ceo of nature's one which makes organic
baby formula so to make sure his
products are pure ingredients are tested
for heavy metal toxins before they even
reach the building it's constant
surveillance and testing and working
with our suppliers
the finished products are also
periodically tested so hyman can work to
keep toxins like arsenic and lead out of
his products but about 10 years ago it
was a different story we were the poster
child for the first
toxins
identified in certain ingredients in
2012 nature's one made headlines after a
university study found arsenic in its
organic baby formula this 2012 event was
so shocking because
we were in this beautiful place in our
mind that we're doing everything
possible that we could he says his
company was testing for toxins but the
commercial labs he used couldn't test
down to the lower levels in that study
it turned out the arsenic was in an
ingredient called brown rice syrup
customers were furious you must have
lost a lot of business we went to zero
zero
it was difficult time it really was
you're actually tearing up a little bit
well it's it's it's emotional yeah
that he says was the turning point since
then he's dedicated himself to keeping
toxins out without a doubt it hardened
our resolve to
always be ahead of it we want to know
what's in our product but as to other
companies the latest congressional
report looking at toxins in baby foods
says heavy metals are showing up in some
major brands for instance investigators
said two of gerber's infant rice cereal
products contained inorganic arsenic
levels over the fda's limit they said
gerber failed to recall those products
most of plum organics products contained
heavy metals too including popular super
puff snacks and they said walmart raised
the amount of arsenic it allowed in its
products going from an internal company
standard of 23 parts per billion to the
maximum allowed by fda of 100 parts per
billion subcommittee chairman
representative raja krishnamurthy no
level of toxic heavy metals and exposure
to them
is safe for a baby we reached out to the
companies named gerber did not answer
whether it failed to recall products but
told us it follows a consistent and
rigorous testing plan which includes
regular testing of finished products and
increases testing for products that have
a history of naturally occurring levels
of heavy metals walmart told us it
requires products to meet fda guidelines
that its specifications have always been
aligned with or below fda requirements
and it's committed to providing high
quality baby food products that are safe
and nutritious but representative
krishnamoorthy wants stronger federal
standards so you don't believe that this
can be left up to the companies to fix
this correct they haven't so far
shown either the capacity or the
willingness to regulate themselves you
need a federal regulator in the form of
fda
to be regulating them closely but jay
hyman says i don't wait for government
to
lead me to that destination it's up to
me to have a conscience from my consumer
it's cost us more to go through this
process but
is there really any price you wouldn't
pay to remove a toxin that's harmful to
a child in its later years or
development years i say no
the report also said some samples of
beechnut products had more inorganic
arsenic than the fda's limit and a
subsequent recall in june was too narrow
beechnut told us that is incorrect the
company says it proactively withdrew all
those rice cereal products from
supermarket shelves and decided to stop
selling infant right products in fact
because it's concerned about being able
to get rice flour that's well below the
fda guidance level now christian morphe
wants to have fda's timelines moved up
but the agency told us that it's crucial
that measures to limit toxic elements in
foods do not have unintended
consequences such as making it more
difficult guys for families to get the
foods you don't want to cut off supply
of foods um and you know you need to
balance out a baby's diet totally so
parents who are at home boiling
vegetables are they in the clear here
they have to worry as well no see and
and the problem is that this stuff is in
the environment right it's in the food
it can be in the produce so the fact
that you might be making baby food at
home is not a solution really so what
they advise you to do is balance out
your diet you can pay attention to
reports that come out from various
groups on which companies seem to have
higher or lower levels
a lot of experts say don't panic
but just try to make sure that the baby
gets a very diet and watch out for
particular things um you might want to
read the numbers on you know rice
products read up on that a little bit
yeah see if you see if you feel okay
with rice products or not as a parent
hard not to panic when it's your baby
and babies can't tell you no mom dad
this doesn't taste so good right it's
important you're bringing this story
thank you anna thank you